hey guys came here and I've got another
GS news update for you titanfall has
claimed the top spot in the UK sales
charts after his lunch on Friday last
week as well as helping to boost
british-based sales of the Xbox one ea's
mech tacular shooter has used its giant
robot hands to grab the title for best
selling opening weekend of 2014 so far
Dark Souls 2 which also launched on the
same day took the second place the
number crunchers at gfk chart-track also
said that titanfall contributed to a
massive upswing in sales of the xbox one
itself with sales virtually doubling
thanks for titanfall Xbox one bundle
seventy percent of Xbox one sales
overall where the bundle and console
sales were up just over ninety six
percent in total dark souls 2 landed in
second as I mentioned before boosting a
twenty percent increase in opening
weekend sales over the original south
park the stick of truth last week's
number one drops to third titanfall will
have to fight hard to keep the numeral
uno spot next week as new contenders
metal gear solid ground zeroes and
infamous second son will also enter the
fray to find out every successful and
it's defense and anything else on
titanfall keep your eyes on gamespot com